in his quest to make America great again
President Donald Trump has spent a week
encouraging us all to buy products that
are made in America that's a good slogan
who doesn't want to help homegrown
businesses but it's a bad and incoherent
policy most of all it will do little or
nothing to help Americans who have been
put out of work by changes in the
economy for starters it's hard to even
get a clean definition of what it means
to be made in America the Jeep Patriot
for instance pushes nationalism in its
very name but its transmissions are made
in Japan Germany and Mexico the same is
true for dozens of products that carry a
made in America tag often a lot of
something is assembled or sourced
outside the United States and only a
little bit of Labor is added within our
borders the United States often has much
higher labor cost in foreign countries
which means the same thing created
solely in America would have an
astronomical cost according to one
estimate if Apple iPads were made in
America they would cost nine hundred and
sixty-seven dollars a piece or about
three times
today's basic price the resulting fall
in sales would cost about 67,000
manufacturing jobs it's made in America
right here at the White House we have
all sorts of beautiful equipment and
other items on the lawn in the Rose
Garden pushing made in America carries
other costs to to hype his policy
president Trump invited 50 exemplary
companies to the White House for a
photo-op
it turns out that 21 of them received
various federal state and local
subsidies worth about six hundred
million dollars if you're taxing Peter
to subsidize Paul chances are you're not
creating much real economic activity
made in America it's the best pushing
economic nationalism is also an affront
to personal liberty and basic economics
why shouldn't people be able to buy
products they find the best wherever
they come from you might as well tell
people the only date American or
vacation American we will follow two
simple rules buy American and hire
American virtually all economists agree
that protectionism dampens economic
activity and growth by increasing prices
and keeping workers and resources in
sunset industries that will need more
and more help to stay afloat one study
of Industry specific protectionist
policies found that trying to make
by American led to consumer losses per
job save of over half a million dollars
and for all the talk Donald Trump and
others have made about bringing back
good-paying manufacturing jobs to
America the fact is that manufacturing
jobs as a percentage of the workforce
peaked in 1943 and has declined ever
since we're truly a post-industrial
nation there's no question that even
with historically low unemployment rates
many Americans are having trouble
finding good-paying rewarding jobs in a
global economy that demands constant
upgrades and changes from workers but
the best way to help them is by pursuing
policies that will create new jobs new
opportunities and new wealth for all of
us lower government spending flatter and
less distorting taxes and less
regulation telling us all the by
American is a cheap slogan that's best
left on baseball caps that will almost
always be made overseas
[Music]